THE GAME WHILE
THEY HAVE REBUILT LAZARS
THE
ZONE.
PASTRNAK TO FOLIGNO
LOOK AT
IT.
AND HE'S GOT HIS EYES
A LITTLE
BIT EARLIER WITHKILL PE.
JORDAN MARTINOOK WILL
ANGLE IN
AND MCAVOY COMES WITH TE
WHEELS ON.
AHO, AGAINST MIKE
REILLY.
CROSS ICE
HOPING THEY
WILL DIRECT THAT PUCK
AWAY FROM
THE FRONT SAVE
SOMETHING
ON THEM ON THE
REBOUND.
A NICE PLAY ON T IT
OFF FOR AHO.
VINCENTIN SKATES IS DENY
ULLMARK.
RIGHT
DOWN TLIGNO,
AND TRENT.
ANDSVECHNIKOV
SCORES.
HE'S A SNIPER.
IT OUT
INTO THAT
AREA.
THAT'S GOT TO BE A
HARD PLAY.
I MEAN YOU TAKE
N THE BOOTH
JUST A SIMPLE SHOT ON
GOAL.
INGLASS
AND NIEDERREITER IN
FRONT,
STALLED DEN MAD
YOU KNOW, HAM
PROTECTIVE NETTING.
NUMBER IT.
>> BLOCK